[Music]
the faa is confirming what we all
suspect there was a surge in incidents
involving unruly passengers in the sky
last year the agency reports get this a
total of almost 6 000 incidents while
flight crews are the first responders in
such cases they often get help from air
marshals cbs news is getting rare access
to the special undercover law
enforcement group earl barnett has more
die die a simulation of a worst case
scenario
a mid-flight hijacking exactly what
federal air marshals are training to
stop
at this sprawling facility in new jersey
we are tasked with patrolling and
securing the skies and there are
thousands of them flying in pairs daily
as they're always undercover we cannot
show you their faces but chances are
they've likely sat next to you on a
flight laying low we are ready for
anything we're 100 trained and know
exactly how to deal with certain
situations another drink for me these
days that means unruly passengers in
december two air marshals broke their
cover on this flight from dc to los
when a angeles became combative what
circumstances will an agent intervene
and what things will they allow the
flight crew to handle if a situation
gets to a point where it's an arrestable
offense an assault or something to a
much higher gravity then we'll
absolutely intervene future air marshals
have to be precise in changing
conditions
training here in low-light scenarios
with moving targets and even a replica
of a first class cabin layout you may
have upwards of 300 passengers on some
of these aircraft so the last thing that
we want to have happen is one of our air
marshals accidentally shoot
innocent persons we have some of the
highest marksmanship standards out of
any federal agency out there federal air
marshals would you say they're the best
shot in the biz yes
they're proof
a marksmanship score which measures
accuracy what's your accuracy i am
shooting at 287 287 out of 300 yes this
recruit who we cannot identify had no
previous law enforcement experience i
wanted something bigger than me get back
get back new high is slow during the
pandemic drop the weapon but this year
three new graduating classes are kicking
off an effort to fill the ranks the
agency making it a priority to recruit
from underrepresented groups you know
sometimes situations where i feel like a
female would be better suited to handle
a situation you will be the last line of
defense on an aircraft should something
go wrong how does that feel it's a big
job
but it's an honor
now these air marshals fly
internationally but they fly many more
domestic flights these days because of
the pandemic and the increase in unruly
incidents now we pressed the agency to
find out which routes were more common
and they wouldn't divulge that
information but they do confirm in using
quote all available intelligence when
determining where these agents will fly
and if you or your friends are
interested gail they are hiring
listen i just like knowing that they're
there that's what i like and i also like
when max said to you we're ready for
anything but but on that subject errol
uh if anything should include attempting
to save human life by firing a weapon on
the plane uh is that i mean what happens
to those bullets
what are the calculations that they have
to make in terms of keeping the whole
plane in the sky while also neutralizing
the threat
well that's the ultimate question that
they carry the answer to it's a last
resort to fire a weapon in a closed
cabin that could of course cause more
damage and so these air marshals do
everything they can to hang back if an
unruly incident takes place they won't
intervene unless the flight crew is in
danger unless those passengers pose a
real risk to the flight we've seen some
flights have to return to their to their
origin because of unruly incidents so
the air marshals won't get involved
unless things are really turning left
and just be aware they're hanging low
and discreet so they may be on your
flight and you have no idea
all right thank you errol i sat next to
an air marshal once and i said you're
the air marshal right what do you say
he said i cannot answer that question
i can't answer that question ma'am i go
ma'am that's it
that's you errol thank you very much i
really am i'm so glad that they're there